hello
oh my gosh i i uh
we've known each other a long time and
here we are like i don't know do you
feel like a grown up yet
i have my moments i have my moments when
all my clothes are folded and put away
that i'm like yeah i'm crushing this
adult thing
i mean i i actually have a picture of
you from one of our halloween parties
and this was we had known each other for
a while at this point
you know who the guy next to me is um do
tell
that's my husband and your halloween
party was our second date
i mean how crazy is that and you looked
so cute you looked like um
like a hot androgynous like femme dude
from like a fellini film
that is probably the best compliment i'm
gonna get
all day maybe all week because that is
my dream and that's what i kind of
always aspire to
but um my costume uh that year was los
angeles
and i imagined that i was um a starlet
who had uh kind of fallen on hard times
been run over
and my hairdo in that was a
wig that reminded me of a 17 magazine
shoot that you did when i was a teenager
that i spent all summer
trying to replicate but it was
impossible because you have angel hair
and mine
is lovely but it is brown and straight i
had a crush on you that night
and i'm always crushing on you i mean
you are just so stunning and
i have been such a huge fan of yours for
so long
and now it's me and my daughters who
like
just freak out i mean there's ella
enchanted that they
literally binged like since the moment
they
came out into this world
i mean i've seen ella enchanted maybe
500 times
i know it line for line oh yeah
um and i love it so much and
then my daughters and i binge and love
bride wars it's one of our favorite
films and actually
um june diane and casey wilson came on
the show
and we talked all about it oh they're
the best they're so
funny i remember when i read that script
i was um i just i
i was it was just such a quick yes
because it just made me laugh and i
thought they were saying something
i mean the original original script was
there it was a very deep
r-rated film where we wound up with some
a place that was a little more feel good
but
um but they're they're the best and drew
i have to say
um like i was actually kind of in my
head before this interview started
because i'm sitting here going how do i
be normal
with like one of my all-time girl
crushes so the fact that i'm a girl
crush of yours it just means that we
should have been dating
this whole time i think we need to get
this husband out of the picture
well you know i'm really big he's great
truly i think that i think that we can
figure something out
all right he can say maybe
the details later the important thing is
that clearly
coming to the party exactly
i feel really good about this and then
all of our kids can play together listen
this is potting at its ultimate best
we are sprouting seeds of possibility
right now
do you know like when you read a script
and you're just like
i can't stop thinking about it i can't
stop dreaming about it does that happen
with you
yeah yeah i think for me it's if i'm
if i'm reading along with it out loud by
the time i finished it that's a really
good sign
and it i i don't have the capacity to
really describe it
i'm not trying to be overly serious
about the process i just don't know how
to describe it but if there is something
electric to it yeah it's like something
inside my bones
just starts uh firing and um
and then once i'm and then once i'm in
i'm really really in i like to dive deep
and
um and i yeah part of me is always
thinking about it
you are in all these films that we love
so much that we love to cozy into but
then you're in like
indies like rachel getting married and
then you're in les miz winning an
oscar but it's still ella enchanted
devil words product bride wars
you've managed to transcend like not
being
pigeonholed in any way you can do modern
love
and sing and dance you can be in the
witches with this extraordinary
accent and i feel like you've done such
an amazing job at creating a ride that
anyone will get on and believe
the genre tone and story that you are
telling without saying
i know what this is going to be and
that's not easy to do thank you
i'm i'm i could be silent and and just
absorb that
for a lot longer but that would be very
fun for your audience so i'm just going
to
thank you so much i can't tell you what
that means to me i'll probably email you
about it later
but um but i honestly thank you you're
giving me way
too much credit i think when you look at
all of those films you have to look at
the directors
who just kind of because you know how it
is we do our best we we give the raw
material to them but then it takes on a
whole nother life and the director is
the one that
guides it and edits it and and then you
know kind of guides the music that goes
on top of it
and um and so when i think of those
performances i think
that's the reason why i i may if i've to
this point managed to avoid being
pigeonholed it has to be because i've
just had such incredible directors
protecting me
and uh making sure that it felt
different i think that's an
excellent point i am i love directors
um and they do really mold and they set
the tone
like you're a wonderful director oh my
gosh
thank you director is that is that
something that you love are we going to
see more of that i'm sorry to put you on
the spot but
no i i had i had my kids and you know
the directing job and i'm so psycho
about everything i do
that i just i had to stop for a while i
wanted to like
you know just raise my kids for a while
and then
i went back to work in this show called
santa clarita diet and it was like
such a blessing because it you know
what i mean just like candy you could
just i can just watch you forever
when i'm i like just like scrolling
through channels and i come on and i see
your face
i'm just so happy it gives me the best
feeling and i always stop because i got
to see what you're up to
in the scene it doesn't matter how many
times i've seen it and so anyway i
didn't mean to cut you off but you're
great in santa clarita
oh my god thank you so much i'm i first
of all i'm amazed and thrilled that you
know what it is a i watch television yes
i know i'm amazed by myself too
but it like it reminded me that i had a
skill set because i had totally lost it
like i had become
so kid-oriented that i kind of forgot
who i was
and it was nice to be reminded that
i you know because also if you psycho
stare your kid in the face they're gonna
end up in therapy so it was like
there was a i feel like i'm i'm going
through something similar like that
right now
and it's it's a funny thing and i hope
we get there as a culture that we
because i feel like we talk about these
things as though there are specific line
breaks
as opposed to another thing which is
like this accumulation this accumulation
of life experience and wisdom and and
each
and everything builds on each other and
there's like a layering involved to it
and um i just i just think that uh i
don't know i just hope
we get to that point where because i
think that
i don't know why exactly maybe it's
because there's this history
uh you know of looking at ourselves in
these specific
ways and we're just getting to a point
where
we're more relaxed and accepting that
we're we're all sorts of different
things and they
and whether or not you have kids is is
you know that that's not actually
relevant to this conversation but
but that way of seeing each other as
whole beings who do many many different
things
i'm really glad to hear you say that
[Music]